et pour ce face à face nous accueillons
virginie pradel présidente de l'institut
vauban fiscaliste bonsoir ça à vos côtés
michel henry avocat justement des
salariés d'arjowiggins donc je me tourne
vers vous dans cette affaire on affaire
à qui un fait divers avec des ex crowe
ou alors c'est une affaire qui révèle
finalement plus que ça je crois qu'au
premier degré il ya un fait divers un
peu caricatural avec des gens que le
mandataire de justice a qualifiés de
bandes d'aigrefins qui ont repris
l'entreprise qu'ils ont pillé et qui ont
déposé le bilan très rapidement en
laissant de l'établissement industriel
qui n'avait plus aucun élément d'actif
mais au-delà de ces cinq derniers mois
de vie de cette entreprise qui n'est pas
à l'origine c'est arjowiggins security
c'était une filiale d'arjowiggins
spécialisée dans la fabrication de
papier sécurisé pour les cartes grises
passeports et billets de banques
deux étrangers il ya en arrière-plan
le groupe auquel appartenait cette
société quel groupe sequana dont
arjowiggins security était une
sous-filiale et ce groupe a fait un
choix il ya une dizaine d'années qui
était d'abandonner la filière papetière
qui avait fait l'histoire du groupe arjo
et d'orienter son activité ou sa
recherche de profils vers la
distribution de papier c'est l'autre
moitié du sous groupe qui s'appelle
antalis et le le projet a été réalisé
par la fermeture successive d'une
dizaine de papeterie en france qui
constituait la force industrielle
d'argent alors c'est la maîtrise ont été
fermées les unes après les autres
wizernes dans le nord et d'affaires du
mans à peu près en même temps que
carrefour higgins a mais avec néanmoins
un plan social et un plan social adossé
aux capacités d'un groupe qui en avait
plus beaucoup de capacités mais c'était
quand même là c'est un groupe qui avait
une certaine puissance là l'opération a
été particulièrement pernicieuse parce
qu'elle a consisté à vider totalement
les caisses de la filiale arjowiggins à
faire remonter
l'argent qui restait dans la société
mère il compte notamment l'argent de la
vente des filiales d'arjowiggins
security et de une fois que la société a
été entièrement vidé de ses actifs de
trouver un repreneur
et alors ce dont on peut s'étonner quand
même c'est que cette reprise qui a
épargné au groupe sequana le coup d'un
plan social a reçu la bénédiction du
tribunal de commerce d'un administrateur
dans le cadre d'une procédure de
conciliation qui est une procédure très
secrète au tribunal de commerce
du ministère des finances de la banque
publique d'investissement est
l'interlocuteur de ceux de ce groupe de
deux personnes et de sociétés qui ont
été le le le le consortium de reprise
d'arjowiggins
la principale personne qui était
l'interlocuteur à la fois des salariés
des dirigeants et bercy monsieur
terrorriste c'est quelqu'un qui était
sous contrôle judiciaire et un gros
qu'il y avait déjà été condamné par le
tribunal de commerce de versailles pour
banqueroute frauduleuse et donc
l'incompréhension c'est de savoir
comment on a pu ignorer
voilà le passé nous le présente sept 7
personnes justement virginie pradal
c'est vrai que c'est une interrogation
c'est facile aujourd'hui pour une
personne qui a de l'argent de racheter
ce ce type de société sans contrôler ces
eaux vit dans un système comme celui ci
aujourd'hui mais c'est plus complexe à
racheter des sociétés vont c'est très
fréquent n'y a pas de problème ce qui ce
qui confine à la mauvaise farce on fait
dans cette affaire comme l'a très bien
dit connaître et andy michel henri
michel risques identifiés comme l'a très
bien dit voilà c'est que en fait il ya
une conjonction d'événements un peu
farfelu fondé des aides qui ont été
octroyées et ce sans contrôle et ça
révèle quand même que l'état n'est pas
très prévenant dans ce type d'affaires
et que là on assiste quand même une
gabegie assez insupportable alors je
vous propose réagissent et puis après on
va aller plus loin on va laisser de côté
ce cas là vous allez vous devez arrêter
il faut juste apporter une précision
c'est que on n'a pas besoin d'argent
pour acheter un jour boudine sécurité on
en reçoit de l'argent c'est à dire que
le prix de vente était négatif de 17
millions d'euros
donc on reçoit de l'argent donc au delà
de ce cas aujourd'hui au fond est-ce que
les contraintes pour les chefs
d'entreprise finalement sont moindres
que pour les salariés et est ce que
c'est une bonne chose selon vous
virginie pradal les contraintes sur les
chefs d'entreprise non mais il ya quand
même beaucoup de contraintes ne faut pas
non plus faire un amalgame là c'était
des défunts de manière plus générale en
sortant dans ce cas là est ce
qu'aujourd'hui les chefs d'entreprise
ont trop de contraintes suffisamment de
contraintes
oui évident qu'en france on n'est quand
même pas aidé quand on est chef
d'entreprise à savoir qu'on a quand même
une fiscalité assez oppressant et ce qui
nous distingue quand même de nombreux
pays voisins notamment l'allemagne
il ya quand même une pression fiscale
assez insupportable qui s'exerce sur les
entreprises françaises et notamment les
entreprises manufacturières ce qui
contribue bien évidemment est la
désindustrialisation de la france depuis
plusieurs décennies
c'est sûr que alors les faits divers se
succèdent mais même au niveau des
statistiques on constate que la part de
l'industrie manufacturière dans la
valeur ajoutée globale a chuté de
plusieurs points en 20 ans elle est
passée de plus de 16% à peu près 11 % ce
qui est moitié moins qu'en allemagne où
on atteint quasiment 23%
donc à un moment il faut se poser la
question et j'ai l'impression que
personne ne se la pose vraiment que
faire pour aider les entreprises et a
fortiori des industries manufacturières
qui comme on le sait participe
énormément au maintien de l'emploi dans
les territoires qui sont de plus en plus
des oeuvres et voilà est qui qui crée un
peu des poches de précarité dans notre
pays justement michel henry les salariés
que vous avez rencontré les salariés que
vous défendez qu'est-ce qu'il vous dise
on nous a pas défendu on nous a pas
assez défendu on n'est plus reconnue on
est plus à ses protégés ça passe par là
aussi le pain de l'entreprise rohde
n'ont eux il ya les salariés
d'arjowiggins en particulier ils disent
rien ils ont vu venir ce qui s'est
produit l'ont dénoncé auprès du ministre
d'économie lequel écrit avant le dépôt
de bilan aux dirigeants pour leur dire
vous êtes en train de
conduire la faillite cette entreprise et
vous le fait délibérément bon mais
l'aspect fiscal si vous voulez je ne n'y
en ait pas de connaissances
particulières
ce que je vois c'est que le droit du
licenciement économique qui repose est
quand même sur un équilibre qui était de
tenir compte des réalités économiques
mais de ne pas licencier le personnel
pour accroître les profits
c'était un peu la ligne de démarcation
dans la loi la jurisprudence en or cette
protection dans le droit du licenciement
économique
c'est quand même largement effondré par
les facultés de contournement de ces du
licenciement économique
la succession des textes récents a
permis de développer les plans de
départs volontaires
les ruptures conventionnelles
collectives c'est-à-dire un ensemble de
mécanismes de rupture du contrat de
travail qui ne nécessite pas de
contraintes importantes et qui ne
permettent pas ensuite de contestation
non plus devant le conseil des
prud'hommes donc il ya des départs
massifs dans les entreprises qui se font
souvent sur la base d'un apparent
volontariat avec les incitations
financières
et tout cela je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse dire que ça crée beaucoup de
contraintes alors il ya un plus un autre
phénomène c'est que le droit de la
faillite
lui est utilisé pour faciliter les
restructurations industrielles comme en
ce sens que ces contraintes qui se sont
amoindries ces dernières années elle
n'existe presque plus du tout dans le
droit de la faillite vous déposer le
bilan
le mandataire de justice n'a que
quelques jours pour faire un pse il ya
plus d'argent dans la caisse il peut pas
en inventer la société appartenait à un
groupe elle n'appartient plus à ce
groupe
souvent et les protections du droit du
travail sur la continuité des contrats
de travail si on trouve un repreneur ne
s'applique plus non plus obligatoirement
donc il ya une je dirais une certaine
forme d'attraction vers l'utilisation du
droit de la faillite pour pour faciliter
les restructurations et licencié des
personnels la virginie pradal vous
partager ce que vient de dire michel
henry à savoir à déséquilibre finalement
entre le le salarié et puis et puis
finalement ceux qui peuvent racheter
mettre en faillite
utiliser le droit du travail au fonds à
des fins personnelles bien entendu mais
les salariés sont les victimes de tout
cela en france ans et c'est vraiment et
les maillons faibles malheureusement
c'est quoi c'est un manque de volonté
des politiques selon vous ces cellules
en fait on le système assez paradoxale
où l'état
communique énormément sur toutes les
aides qui sont attribués aux industriels
et qui sont real 1 mais qui ne sont pas
très contrôlée comme la cette affaire le
révèle mais de l'autre côté l'état ne
fait que compenser les pins ne fait que
compenser les problèmes qu'il génère lui
même en créant une déréglementation
toujours plus complexes et des impôts
toujours plus important parce que
rappelons que en france on est quand
même taxé avant d'avoir fait des
bénéfices bien sûr faut distinguer
différentes choses là la sphère qui est
en cause est une arnaque
enfin grossière à l'horizon non plus se
focaliser que sur cette affaire pour
pour parler des problèmes industriels en
france mais force est de constater que
il ya quand même des velléités
politiques pour réindustrialiser la
france et refaire de notre pays une
force d'attraction en matière
industrielle
alors je vous propose maintenant
d'écouter fiodor rilov c'était l'avocat
des salariés de l'usiné vous diront
souvient il s'exprimait hier sur le
plateau de paul isnard on l'écouté
aurais-je ensuite vous savez qu'il ya eu
plusieurs réformes du code du travail
elle a été fermée il ya six ans
absolument et que dans cet intervalle la
voilà entre 2014 et aujourd'hui hollande
et macron honte enlever du code du
travail
quasiment tous les articles sur le
fondement desquels les salariés de
goodyear font le procès aux prud'hommes
c'est à dire que hollande et macron on
était le code du travail par mon chien
peut très bien pour que des groupes
comme goodyear puisse licencier
désormais sans entrave
michel henry une réaction le code du
travail pour permettre aux enfants de ne
pas payer
vous rejoignez cette analyse je ne
nierai pas chercher les intentions
cachées des auteurs de ces réformes mais
elles vont toutes dans le même sens ce
qui est de d'amoindrir les garanties des
salariés 2
réduire les possibilités de recours de
rendre ces recours difficile illusoire
dans la mesure où les possibilités de
percevoir une indemnisation à la mesure
de son préjudice ont disparu par l'effet
du barème macron et si on ajoute à ça
que dans le cas de la faillite des
faillites impécunieuse comme y'en a
beaucoup celle là en particulier c'est
le fonds de garantie des créances
salariales qui finit par recevoir
l'addition puisqu'elle n'est pas payée
par l'entreprise en faillite
le fonds de garantie ne paye qu'à
hauteur de plafond pour simplifier le
plus élevé de ces plafonds
c'est à peu près 80 mille euros en brut
mais il faut savoir que dans ces
entreprises le fonds de garantie quand
il est sollicité pour payer des
condamnations il a déjà avancé de
l'argent
il a déjà avancé les derniers salaires
jusqu'à la date du licenciement ils à
payer les indemnités de licenciement et
le préavis est par conséquent il n'ya
plus que la marge disponible entre le
plafond est ce qu'il a déjà payé qui
peut couvrir une condamnation alors là
c'est même plus le barème macron c'est
la marge résiduelles et le paradoxe
c'est que plus les salariés ans
d'ancienneté
- cette marge est importante puisque
leurs indemnités de rupture sont plus
importantes que ceux qui ont moins
d'ancienneté de telle sorte que pour
simplifier par exemple dans la sphère
arjowiggins les cadres n'ont plus de
marge disponible pour la plupart ils ont
tous reçu une indemnisation de la gs
hauteur de la totalité de ce qui peut
être couvert par la chaise et même les
ouvriers ils ont généralement une marge
disponible de garantie de la gs qui se
situe entre 150 et 300 milles entre
15000 et 3 et 30000 euros ce qui est
dérisoire au regard de destruction de
leur emploi et leur situation
personnelle
virgile
ils pradel est ce que il y a une volonté
d'amoindrir les garanties des salariés
aujourd'hui selon vous de spanair
français c'est factuel sans volonté
politique et une volonté politique je
pense que dans la logique de macron qui
est celle de rendre la france un peu
plus compétitive pas forcément tous les
cas
vous voyez des entreprises condamnées à
payer de lourdes indemnités à des
salariés faisait mauvais effet à
l'étranger donc je pense que ça va dans
le sens de rendre la france plus
attractives ont malheureusement ça se
fait clairement au détriment des
salariés seul salarié la variable
d'ajustement aujourd'hui à totalement
totalement
il faudrait éviter d'en arriver là oui
l'ont toujours été
mais je veux dire ils le sont d'autant
plus facilement que qu'il ya moins de
protection pour garantir la stabilité de
l'emploi et que les licenciements sont
plus faciles ce que disait fiodor rilov
tout à l'heure c'est exact mais dans la
sphère goodyear les salariés ont touché
le montant des dommages et intérêts qui
leur ont été accordées alors que dans la
sphère arjowiggins il et toucheront pas
en plus ça il est temps que le conseil
des prud'hommes leur accord de cinquante
ou soixante mille euros de dommages et
intérêts ce qui ne remplacera pas les
emplois qu'ils ont perdu et bien la
garantie résiduelle de la gs ne couvrira
que qu'entre une petite aux trois rien
et puis vingt ou trente mille euros sur
le sur ce montant là ça peut être
quelque chose qui deviendrait la norme
plus tard selon vous un génie pradel par
rapport à ce que vous observez
moi ce que je constate de façon globale
ces combats vers une précarisation de
l'emploi
je vous donne un élément tout simple le
gouvernement énormément communiqué sur
la flambée de la créant des créations
d'entreprises en fait qu'est ce que ça
cache sa cache une flambée
de la création de micro-entreprises
alors la micro entreprise a été créée
avec de très bonnes intentions
malheureusement ce dispositif un peu été
paraît même beaucoup et est perverti et
et qu'est ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
sont obligées de recourir à ce
dispositif parce qu'elles ne peuvent
plus être salarié parce que les
entreprises veulent faire des économies
ne veulent pas prendre des risques
donc tout ça contribue à une sorte de
précarisation exacerbé et on voit la
nouvelle économie et une économique
précaire où on bénéficie alors ni de
céder in its est dédé parce que le
gouvernement essaie de combattre les cdd
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est même pu
le penser clairement pu le problème le
problème c'est d'avoir un emploi et de
ne pas recourir à des dispositifs
extrêmement précaire et ce qu'ils font
ce à quoi il faut faire attention c'est
la communication du gouvernement par
exemple le gouvernement communique
énormément sur la baisse du taux du
chômage bon relativisons on est quand
même le pays de l'union européenne par
le quatrième et de l'union européenne
qui a le taux de chômage le plus élevé
on est a pu lui pour cent quand la
moyenne au sein de l'union européenne
est à 6% et qu'en allemagne on est à 3 %
on est quand même dans un pays qui reste
encore en proie à des vraies difficultés
économiques je vous propose d'écouter
maintenant
xavier mathieu c'était le porte celle
porte parole de la cgt continental
il réagissait hier un toujours d'un
polype mag sur un autre quart
emblématique celui de continental il ya
dix ans sept ans de combat pour faire le
reconnaître le caractère abusif de leur
licenciement pour ses salariés
je vous propose d'écouter et xavier
mathieu porte-parole de la cgt
continental et ce qui est terrible c'est
que aujourd'hui les conti encore plus de
la moitié des mecs qui sont à la rue
compass de travail et en ayant eu des
indemnités assez colossal à l'époque on
a réussi à se battre on a réussi à avoir
tous que avec les lois mac ronde les
gens ne pourront plus avoir ce qui veut
dire c'est que les gens aujourd'hui onze
ans après il y en a la moitié dans la
merde
et encore on a réussi à se battre et à
obtenir des indemnités qui ont fait que
les gens le temps a duré était un peu
moins dure le temps de voir des gens à
l'avenir là ils vont se faire virer et
en plus avec rien voilà xavier mathieu
l'ancien porte-parole de la cgt
continental on l'entendait ils vont se
faire virer et avec rien dix ans après
puisqu'il ya eu entre temps des réformes
vous l'expliquez comment michel henri
salesse et ses observations pour penser
une vieille jurisprudence qui est l
affaire cricket ou avant que législation
sur le licenciement économique ne soit
tout à fait défini il ya une entreprise
qui avait
appelé les salariés à se présenter à la
direction pour toucher un chèque
s'il partait volontairement de
l'entreprise en plus les gens étaient
endosser endetté plus il faut se
précipiter pour aller prendre le chèque
et on l'a retrouvé deux ans plus tard
tous ces gens qui étaient partis avec un
chèque tiré un départ volontaire en
surendettement est dans la misère leurs
maisons vendues et ea la rue alors la
jurisprudence avait mis fin
pendant un certain temps à ces pratiques
en considérant que tout départ qui
s'inscrivait dans des motifs économiques
devaient être soumis à la législation
sur le licenciement économique mais
c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui détruit de
manière non pas tout à fait total mais
largement à travers ces mécanismes de
nouveau de plan de départs volontaires
alors avec un minimum de forme une
consultation du comité d'entreprise
une un accompagnement qui est celui des
licenciements économiques
mais enfin le résultat il est que les
gens qui sont le plus en difficulté sont
ceux qui ont le plus besoin le plus
immédiat d'argent et qui sont le plus
tenté de répondre à ces invitations à
partir avec un chèque
alors maintenant s'il fallait se
demander si le gouvernement suit une
logique de déstructuration du code du
travail je crois que ce qui s'est passé
au mois de décembre on est un exemple
flagrant
il ya une loi qui a été votée sans qu'on
y prête beaucoup d'attention qui
permettait aux plateformes savait que
jurisprudence et la cour de cassation
ont récemment jugé que les salariés des
plates formes qui font les services de
livraison à domicile par exemple de
repas en fait avec un contrat de travail
voilà alors qu'on les considérait comme
des des zooms claude et des gens qui
étaient des travailleurs indépendants et
le gouvernement a fait voter un texte
qui a été censuré par le conseil
constitutionnel et qui prévoyait que
c'était les plateformes qui définissait
le elle-même les règles de droit social
qu'elle entendait appliquer et que pour
autant qu'elle définisse une charte en
ce sens dont elle était libre de
déterminer le contenu est bien les
salariés ne pourrait jamais revendiqué
l'existence d'un contrat de travail
là on a trouvé que c'était un peu trop
ça a été censuré je vous propose
d'écouter maintenant avec six poulains
cofondateur du monde moderne est pour
lui le gouvernement n'a pas de projet
pour l'industrie en france si ce n'est
que l'objectif c'est de nettoyer le
monde ouvrier on les écoute il n'y a pas
de plan en fait pour l'industrie en
france il n'y en a jamais eu à vrai dire
il ya un plan par contre c'est pour
effacer et et enlever le monde ouvrier
des radars parce que derrière
depuis toujours le monde ouvrier c'est
le danger en politique c'est le monde
syndical c'est le monde n'est pas
d'accord avec les règles des riches et
ça se voit et c'est devenu pourquoi
aujourd'hui il ya cette ce désamour
aussi de l'industrie c'est que pendant
des années on dit que ce n'était pas une
filière s'étaient pas un emploi c'était
un poil des ravages ouais vous vous
étiez mauvais à l'école et ben se
faisait une formation s'était pas
quelque chose qui était une carrière
virginie travers une réaction ou ses
propos d'alexis poulain effectivement on
n'a pas de plan de l'industrie
aujourd'hui
et l'idée c'est de supprimer les
ouvriers oui ça c'est sûr qu'on n'a pas
vision industrielle en france et ce
depuis plusieurs décennies
mais gageons qu'on va remédier à ce
problème bientôt même si j'ai pas
vraiment l'impression qu'on soit sûr ça
doit c'est qu'il ya des choses assez
juste le fait qu'on n'ait pas vraiment
valoriser les filières manufacturés
afssa c'est aussi une évidence il ya
quand même une voilà beaucoup de une
vision très négative a partagé pendant
plusieurs années
bon après je pense pas non plus que ce
soit l'intention du gouvernement de
détruire la classe ouvrière là je trouve
que c'est quand même un petit peu
excessif ce qui se passe malheureusement
c'est que bas en france on a un modèle
social qu'il faut lé fine enfin qui doit
être financée qui est énormément financé
par les entreprises et notamment par les
cotisations sociales patronales
ce qui fait que malheureusement on a une
industrie qui est faible parce que trop
coûteuse par rapport aux industries
d'autres pays concurrents on est dans un
système ultra concurrentiel aux ultra
concurrentiel pardon au sein de l'union
européenne
je vous parle même pas dans le monde
c'est encore pire si on prend par
exemple la chine et que aujourd'hui on
n'est pas du tout armé pour lutter
contre ces pays parce qu'on est trop
lourd et et voilà qu'on n'a pas fait des
choix très pertinent et que l'état n'est
pas suffisamment à mon sens les
entreprises qui sont dans des
territoires et qui sont qui sont fermées
des unes après les autres avec des
conséquences sociales et économiques
désastreuses comme on le sait mais si
l'on rit n'y restent que quelques
secondes
un mot pour conclure le gouvernement de
rêve d'y faire davantage pour les
salariés pourraient déjà arrêter de
détruire le code du travail
ce serait déjà beaucoup merci beaucoup à
tous les deux merci virginie pradal je
rappelle que vous êtes présidente de
l'institut au banc fiscaliste merci à
vous michel henry rappelle que vous êtes
avocat des salariés d'arjowiggins
security